no my reward so because i'll cut it with
your easy questions
i'm bored as [ __ ]
so no hello how are you if you're on the
street i don't want to know the heavier
questions i'm not happier this question
is like an answer for the board general
practice i've done press conference
do you make money when you do that or no
it was disgusting i don't suck dick
you just sucked it you just yeah that's
not spooky exactly i beg for money
outside banks i go by the bookie and
then i start
it's all but thank you much for knowing
that about me have you been stalking me
interesting so
you're just self-destructing and there's
nothing no i'm not i i don't think
you're ever going to do the hotel room
the other day
i don't think you're ever going to
change until you just get so fed up with
your yeah you're probably in my early
20s you're on bs there's more like a 35
it's like an early 30s thing
[Music]
uh one see i was disgusting
i'm trying to pass out but i couldn't
pass the house what was it on
uh
it's like three grams and i would sleep
when i woke up i was really around
anyway uh yawn
it's during the vinyl we have a problem
here exactly
what have you been up to mark yeah
what have you been up to i had a fun
little dinner date with you the other
day yeah yeah at the jack in the box
my car was a disaster after you left i'm
so sorry i know i would have cleaned it
up but you're not paying me enough
i'm terrible made i tried it once i
sucked on myself yeah i just want to get
paid so i put my name on the [ __ ]
list of the means that morning
clean one room i completed [ __ ] but i
got paid
i paid 20
anyway neon
what part of skid row do you hang out in
motion it's a one skid row there's only
like one skid row but there's certain
streets and there's certain i don't know
all the ones i don't know i don't know i
don't want
you seem to be on the 6th street quite a
bit yeah mostly things in san pedro
honestly so i got the clothes and the
drugs and cigarettes what are you
wearing today i'm wearing oh this is
this gown it's torrid and oh michelle
then
shows my
dumpster you get most of your clothes
out of a dumpster what what what's next
to the dumpster right adjacent
all right some people stand and see
affirmative people say oh [ __ ]
what happened to your foot oh i got a
needle stuck in my [ __ ] heel look at
your feet look at my feet yeah you don't
want to know stories
i know i know it's fine we'll have our
bottle scars you have the dirtiest feet
if anyone i've ever seen well how
comfortable you have it dirty just like
i don't have a shower i don't shower
i don't shower i don't shower you don't
go to the refresh center and take a
shower sometimes
yeah
so they wouldn't let me into the cross
but it was a spot once at 3am was the
last time you took a shower two weeks
ago i don't know
cut it out i thought it's true
fine
[ __ ] you got a pair of pliers
you don't have a gap just like have you
lost teeth yet huh have you lost any
teeth yet yeah just the sun it never
grew back i was like 12.
but i'm like
since you've been homeless huh since
you've been homeless no i've lost any
teeth i haven't even been pushed to the
face once
you haven't what i've been punched in
the face i've been kicking nothing yeah
don't say to me they're going to be
money they're good people they're
homeless people you know what i mean
they have to take me they'll hate you
for no reason
because they're in their savages my feet
are killing me i'm sorry
it's a disaster so you're spending your
night doing sexual no i don't think i'm
i masturbate
i don't have time to deal with someone
else's [ __ ] they suck my dick that's
like my old dad put it in my wallet i
put it in my hoo hump
i don't know what time is that [ __ ] i
must make it 5-20 minutes and same
orgasm and it's perfect
but whatever
safer i'm sure safer but also more more
um
you have more it's like um a higher
success rate of of coming you know what
i mean
like you know you're gonna come when
you're masturbating the goal is to come
whenever sometimes you don't come you
get tired and you just doze off you know
sexist
aerobics no i don't think i'm gonna pull
out of you
i don't run the math
sucks like oh you gotta move around and
hump
like gay sex is easier honestly because
like positions you know what i mean but
whatever i'm sorry my feet are killing
me
but i'm sober right now so we're as a
fish no you're not yes i am sorry
24 hours that's why you're talking a
mile a minute yes exactly because i'm
bored you're bored when you're sober
this is how you are when you're when
you're sober yeah why am i suffering
because i'm broke
so when i'm sober listen when i'm high
you know i mean
class you know new york elegant
jazzy or whatever i'm sorry i
and if you had enough money to buy
whatever you want what would you buy
dresses drugs
and um
and you were and diamonds yeah
dressed as drugs diamonds does have that
slightly mark they're like kitschy maybe
little honors okay i just [ __ ] yeah
it looks disgusting
ugh
i hate my feet [ __ ]
i have these pains i can't get in my
nerve endings but they can't get into
the hospital
i scan my feet there's no broken bones
i'm like yeah but the skin hurts
it's still dumb anyway whatever next
question
do you want to go take a shower and
shave
i'd love to wear
right across the street kind of the
hotel mm-hmm do you know how room you
need i'll get your room just give two
bucks don't know we can shout out
you don't have time for that yeah
because i only have cable on tv you know
what i mean and if i get stuck you know
when you watch the end of watching pass
out you don't have like youtube or
whatever you need
you're gonna buy another phone though i
need a new phone you'd rather have
youtube than tv yeah exactly just music
if you want to buy me a new phone i need
a new phone
you want to buy another phone
but you're probably too broke every
other day all right you're on our team
you know every other day i'll buy you a
new phone oh daddy uh oh
approach your penis
but you've been on them before i've been
on all of them especially really good
things
you know what i mean the more the more i
learn about everything down here and
this place so i don't know i love it
they got nothing here they don't have a
mcdonald's mark
why don't they have a mcdonald's in skid
row why is this place like that it's all
warehouses and [ __ ]
like [ __ ] pipe shops there's a
mcdonald's three blocks up no we have
another country's outside
just in the row oh right in the middle
of it right no it's at the end of
schedule by the ground station i know
right and it's not three blocks it's ten
blocks i walked it last night
yeah i guess you're right it's not ten
it's ladies
we're both meeting in the middle
oh we got you
your feet are disgusting
someone sent me an email
or uh i think it was an email of uh of
you squirming around yeah i wanna see
that yeah i love to see you guys you
were just laying out there i was also in
the bank and i'm just going around my
head was
in the streets
like my face
[Music]
i'm really irritating you know i don't
stop you know
so like you're not irritating you're
supposed to people take like coffee
breaks smoke
or anything
but this chanel bag though
you win again
i'm so bored mark what do you what do
you what do you want for your life what
do you want to do
do you want you want to find a rave
honestly
israelis around here no there aren't
where not anymore nothing's going the
warehouses in the warehouse district
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah no no
no they're not the [ __ ] stupid
spanish cholula place [ __ ] like a
real rave like a real underground very
technology i found some like i found one
there was like some gallery doing some
[ __ ] like and you know where the
warehouse is in the warehouses trick but
i got lost like i got really lost i
couldn't find like i could never go back
yeah my [ __ ] top lips are [ __ ]
oh my god
oh [ __ ]
i can't deal with this [ __ ] foot [ __ ]
so over at mark
eventually you'll get tired of yourself
no i love myself i'm i'm on no no no no
not you're talking to myself i get
smoked by myself i love myself i'm i'm
the best
tired of your lifestyle no never i'm
young
i'm young dumb and full calm yeah i'm
young young's [ __ ] 24 [ __ ]
what what am i going to do well i like
your poses though married to me or
masculine you like my nipples
they're
i can't tell if you're happy or
depressed
i am
like oh i'm pissed off because you're
bored
that's also my backstage so you're just
bored i was born at af what the [ __ ]
right now you want cigarettes you want
drugs
i want something to do well i got to
take this in the drugs
had a great job doing something you'd
love to do with that yeah i mean i would
try i i was like sorry well those are
modern ones
yeah you gotta do the same thing all
over again don't look repetitive you
know what i mean like i like jobs like
you know like freelancing [ __ ] but i
don't like repetitive gigs
so job like i don't like stability i
don't like repetitive no do you find you
find something that works for you what
am i gonna [ __ ] get a job at some
double or like a [ __ ]
world traveler no no no no no no
i got paid enough banking outside the
banks like ten dollars an hour mark
give me a blood test mark i swear i'm
sorry i'm so sorry what if i give you
money and you end up dead tomorrow i
don't do needles you're only overdosed
on needles i can't die mark i can't die
i don't die my one thing rebecca never
doesn't like kenny from just working i
don't i
can't kill me
i'll be on beautiful forever baby
okay can you buy your lunch
sure can you can you buy my phone
no i'm not gonna buy your phone you'll
lose it
okay fine because you're not like not
giving me money just like the last one
did you say last what do you want to say
what do you want to say to all your fans
out there you've got a whole bunch of
them now okay hey it's rebecca i love
you guys and always remember
a woman's greatest accessory is her
style
sincerely rebecca madame
i know shout out mark chelsea shout out
to a shout out hollywood shout out to a
shout out of course kate mall shout out
to kate moss particular and all of you
you want to live like me
real easy just [ __ ] do it don't make
excuses
i do drugs kids don't work
bye
right anyway
what drugs did you do last night
um just like a little bit of glass and
wine
what's the matter i'm worried about you
what do you mean
you seem to be
having a hard time this morning
did you sleep last night
not really
you're beautiful
but you're a mess
because i guess you're a hot mess
it makes you a hot mess what do you need
you need a room
i don't think you'll sleep
um
so molly and meth and no sleep this is
what we get
you seem wound up
all right well thank you for stopping by
i'll let you go
i don't even know what to ask you
i don't think you can even ask and
answer anything
i didn't know how to help you i don't
know how to what to do first
what do you think you need what do you
what do you think would help you
a year in jail
a year in jail
[Music]
a year in a cell might
get you clean some psych meds maybe
[Applause]
oh rebecca oh mark
you're getting worse and worse i think
i don't know i just had a really entire
night
every night for you
it's rough
even when i put you up in a motel room
or hotel i want you foreign
no no no i'm not going to pay for
another i bought you so many rooms and
you never use these you only did it once
please take a shower
in your shower and just i'll give you
another chance i'll try it again okay
but i bet you don't come back clean you
know i'll come back clean look at your
legs yeah my legs are filthy covered in
[ __ ]
tarmac and concrete and
well it's called a runway isn't it
you like this life
this is the life you've carved out for
yourself here
where do you think it's going to go from
here
it could improve i think you're more
likely to be dead than than improving
unless you make some serious well then
i'm better off dead then
i think you're better off dead than
than where you're going to be
doing this every day
i don't know
i don't know everyone has to be such a
i'm sorry
never mind
i don't know about your personal life
and your personal friends but so many
people on my
that
view watch my channel are in love with
you they love you well then i love you i
think i love you too
i love yourself because i can only do so
much for you without your cooperation
well i'm willing to cooperate but
i love you like
i love you too i wish we could
actually spend
human time together we can we had lunch
the other day
we can do it again
but but i think i think what you need is
something like some serious changes yeah
positive changes yeah but you're not
willing to make them i am willing to
make no you're all talk
no i'm willing to make some
i just want to be a woman goddammit
i just want to be a woman
i don't know if i can help you with that
oh god
hug
well shaving off your beard would be a
good start oh my goodness
we can set you up at that
give you a room to shower and shave and
you can get your hair cut
if you want
yeah
phone it just needs to be conditioned
when's the last time you were in a comb
through that
i don't know i can't remember last year
probably yeah
you're depressed most of the time right
i'm not i'm actually not
i'm actually mostly happy during the
really
most of the time
i'm just really depressed
today my sleep will probably help
sleep are just a sense of like socialism
like
socialization i don't know you know you
don't have any friends
you walk around
with nobody to interact with right
yes
[ __ ]
you're frustrating because you're you
have so much
potential so many great qualities
you're just like self-destructing
oh
all right you want me to get your room
sure yeah let's do it
i'll get you
again i'll get you shampoo soap
shaver thanks
thanks
thanks mark
sorry
just wish i was in a better mood today
look at you you're like a work of art
hold on
you don't feel like work of art i didn't
feel like work of art
what do you feel like
[Music]
i feel like a [ __ ] mess
check the wreck of the hospitals
what'd you do recently
no i just passed out i don't know
i got your room last week at the hotel
across the street i got you a phone in a
hotel and i got you all the cleaning
supplies
but look at you oh god do you think you
could help me out with another room
i can do that will you stay in it this
time
possibly yeah i think last time i'll
take a shower yeah yeah take a shower
clean up clean up
your hair looks nice but you should
probably cut it
yeah it's probably gonna find some
animals living in shape oh god
raccoons or something there's probably a
raccoon living in your god
yeah you look pretty rough yeah
you're still beautiful though
you don't need to say that i don't need
to i just do it i think you're beautiful
yeah i'll get your room
get your phone too
thanks a third or fourth phone i think
third or fourth yeah yeah
no but nobody hangs onto their phones
here
yeah
oh this is their phones
here wipe your nose ah thank you
oh god
showering just wasn't your thing that
night
i guess not
guys in a shower
you shower and shave
will you come back after you shower and
shave i bet you look like a
totally different person yes yeah i
suppose
i love that one video of you where you
you were clean-shaven and
you had a nice haircut you you're
you're very handsome
what are you thinking
nothing really
i feel completely vacant
last time you were here after after the
interview we we got you on the phone
with a childhood friend of yours
yeah who was talking about maybe coming
out here and trying to help you out yeah
that'd be nice yeah
because you don't listen to me
you're stubborn
oh it's been very stubborn
if you told me a lot about your
childhood
which i won't talk about here because
you don't want to talk about it but
it's nice to know what was going on
it kind of explains a lot
i'm just kind of dazed
did you sleep
yeah
did you did you get high
a little bit earlier
all right let me get your room you just
need to sleep
no
i just need to relax i guess
curl up in the back fall asleep
can you sleep here
you'll be the first person i let sleep
here
just be quiet through the interviews
yeah i just don't have much to say right
now yeah i understand
all right i'll let you do whatever you
want to do i'll give you some money to
do it
thank you just don't get high
you don't need that right now
i'm gonna do i don't know
all right
what
[Music]
but if you've got the goddamn brains to
know that strangers
[Music]
um
you're divorced um no i'm just talking
about how are you cheating on me
but he's cheating on me
your haircut looks good
it's yours not mine [ __ ]
i like brown pack
that's true
i'm going to be i might i can't bridge
me next to egg cafe i'm sorry i'll be
your beard you want to bring in the next
cup i think that's where the egg
know you're talking so fast i can barely
understand i think with a couple of skid
row you're the sugar daddy i'm like um
i am your sugar daddy
i'm the performer
what
i'm your slime
you're in a fun mood tonight where's the
music no i'm not on board as [ __ ]
[Music]
i told you i was ranch bags
yamaraj child
i'm a
big music what's on the phone
yeah give him my water give me more
money
right now i drink my water
smart water
it's an hour
body
is
pick one i know
pick one
pick one what do you miss about your
whole life i don't [ __ ] that [ __ ] i
killed them i killed them
i don't i don't you don't long for
stability and anything like that
yeah i like how money is about it i
didn't have much money growing up i got
a millionaire about like i had an
allowance and i know my mom was abusive
i don't talk about my childhood
you might talk about your future
i don't think you have a future um you
probably do i probably do you're gonna
you're gonna get tired of this lifestyle
and you're gonna just put it down and
you'll never work in the sound again
you're gonna straight put it down and
just
pick it right back up and uh oh and it's
gonna oh what's this ooh
and it's like
you don't shoot up anymore dad
i'm in the 80s used to do heroin
do you do heroin anymore
anymore do you do any more did you have
it i've never done anything yeah i'm
sure
look run that [ __ ] over look at that
[ __ ] look at that dumb [ __ ] he thinks
he's a raffle does he
can you play any music please
sit in the middle of traffic where's the
phone give me the phone
run him over and run him over
make so much money
the whole pocket was going on
[Music]
pick one
and go
[Music]
rebecca mark what's going on what are
you gonna do tonight i don't know
it's eight o'clock what are you gonna do
party party
since it's monday night it's monday
night
is every night at a party here skid row
no it isn't there's nothing here like
zombies that are dead they're living
dead beautiful people but you're going
to stay up all night of course i'm sorry
i'm a night i'm a nightmare party i'm
partying i'm cleaning the night
that's what i do i live by night do you
get bored no yeah of course i do
did all this all i just got bored
it's how it started you know tell the
whole book started i just i got high i
started talking to myself
well i don't know stuck in my phone so i
do
it's like i'm in my own little world
like i'm alice or dorothy or like i
don't
like i own the place
we're not living in kind of a
concentration camp
you show me your genitalia again oh my
god
well we can't use the footage or can we
i don't know we can use the footage not
on youtube uh we'll see if it gets
deleted
you want to make a bat
million dollars
what do you miss
money
what do you miss in your life yeah money
and older things you barely have shoes
money the olson twins yeah those aren't
shoes those are
birkenstocks
what if creativity became your new drug
i am creative i just don't create
anything i'm very i'm too friendship i
don't think it sounds like old people
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
honestly i don't know you should be a
model i said that's what i'm trying to
do but you know
i aged out you know
you know kate moss she started she's 13.
she's going to jfk by sarah dukas
she's the founder of storm
management
13 jfk
but there's 18 creature died in that
kind of research in her 30s we were just
like in her 50s now
i know she was in a santa ad like two
years ago hey
and next season one season you're in
next season you're out
yeah
still in my teeny you know one cocktail
that ever helps is that sterling martini
why
um
but it's okay risk cutters i love story
thank you for smoking and of course man
can't actually wilson influence
next
um gonna ask you one of my questions i
ask everybody go ahead which i don't
think i've even asked you before but
what what's the most important thing
you've learned in your life rebecca
mary kate now she's also in florida
[Music]
go next question
not a question mark louie that pretty
much says it all
bravo you're the best rebecca i love you
daddy i love you i know
what was that i grew up in colorado
i'm tired of people
you